we have success completely misunderstood
let me tell you what success looks like
work ethic is controllable being born
with talent is not everybody thinks I'm
so lucky and I'm like you're lucky you
went to high school parties there's a
very fine line between perseverance and
delusion the second thing is different
life is to love what you do so much that
you only want to work need motivation
watch a top 10 with the leave nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being born in the Soviet Union
hustlin as a kid selling flowers and
baseball cards building his family wine
business then starting vaynermedia and
being one of the most sought-after
speakers alive he's Gary Vaynerchuk and
he was my take on his top ten rules a
success vol 13 also if you want to know
what Gary and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
money video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below
the reason people are patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one chase happiness happiness is so
important I'm so obsessed with it right
now and I hate that success and
entrepreneurship and all this stuff have
been put on a pedestal do you understand
that most people think they need to make
a million dollars a year to be like
winning meanwhile in America one of the
richest countries in the world four
hundred forty thousand dollars is the
entry into the 1% we we have success
completely completely misunderstood we
have success completely misunderstood
let me tell you what success looks like
when you wake up in the morning and
you're happy
rule number two hustle I talk about
hustle here's why if I looked at all of
us right now and everybody behind these
cameras or reading this article and said
get smarter more talented I want you to
get more talented that's very tricky
that's unbelievably ideological advice
if I said look two extra hours of work
actually has an impact on your success
if that's what you're trying to achieve
that's practical yeah you don't have to
but it's controllable work ethic is
controllable being born with talent is
not rule number three love the dark
clouds everybody wanted to be an
astronaut one day
like it every kid been looking at these
good-looking kids they all want to be
astronauts and pilots in 1957 what do
they want to be now entrepreneurs I mean
this is my moment
and by the way it'll be fun and in 9
years the world will melt
everybody will not be an entrepreneur
anymore it won't be cool they'll blame
entrepreneurship for the melt and I'll
still be an entrepreneur because that's
what I've always been that's what I am
now and that's what I'll be to the last
breath if you're a purebred Asha floor
you love the dark clouds you understand
that the fake entrepreneurship Bureau we
live through loves the sunshine when
it's good and happy and easy but if it's
in your DNA if you actually are not
someone you know exactly why the
upcoming year of dark clouds is going to
be very important because at the end of
the day this is a game based on merit
and if you don't know how to navigate
those storms you can't be in all time on
floor
I love the dark clouds because they're
part of the problem rule number four
change your mindset how many hands work
somewhere but want to do their own thing
raise your hands
more than half this audience meanwhile
let me tell you why most of the hands
that just went up will never get there
they by dumb do you know how many people
here literally drive cars to impress
people that they hate people literally
going in debt or getting further from
leaving the job they don't like to do
something I'll make them happy because
they have to buy a certain car that has
a logo that impresses people that they
despise do you understand how up that is
do you know many people here live in
homes where they don't use more than
half the rooms in the house like we are
so fundamentally in a vortex that makes
no sense that I am unbelievably
passionate understanding how much money
you make and what you can do to get off
of it but the problem is again people
are doing so many things to keep up with
the Joneses to make it look like they're
successful to appease their parents and
a million other things that have nothing
to do with themselves and we need to
change that game rule number five
advertise properly in 1996 my dad had a
liquor store in New Jersey
that's as traditional as you get yeah
that was 22 years ago and and I put my
dad's store on online and I did email
marketing and I did Google and I did
content and then a couple months after
YouTube came out I started a YouTube
show in 2006 which is now 12 years ago I
I I have no respect or and normally I
deploy a lot of empathy I struggled
deploying empathy I struggled deploying
compassion if you were a business
operator in 2018 headache only about
time were recording this in October 2019
which is the majority of people gonna
listen to this and you and your excuses
well I'm a pub
or I make tomato juice or I have three
restaurants like a digital is oxygen
it's it's it's the real world feel
secondary yeah like to not be a
communicator content producer part of
the conversate it's it's now it's gone
from cute and naive to grossly negligent
yeah and I just think it's unacceptable
to be a business in 2019 in the same way
that it would be to pay people not
minimum wage like I literally believe
it's grossly unacceptable like to me
it's like it's like to quantify digital
versus traditional just marketing like
really you think sending direct mail
print is a better thing to do than
advertising on Instagram as a restaurant
like like really like really sit down
with me you're telling me right now that
it's a better deal to spend all that
money making a flier and sending it
direct mail yeah or running a radio ad
or buying a small little ad in a
newspaper like this is what you're
telling me
it is 2019 I felt bad in 2002 was early
the internet was new I had compassion it
was cute in 2007 it was like hmm it was
kind of like uh not like a annoying kind
of like hmm it's still kind of in 2012
like you're not smart in 2019 like yeah
you deserve to die rule number six make
sacrifices everybody thinks I'm so lucky
and I'm like you're lucky you went to
high school parties yeah I worked I went
home 75% of my weekends during my
college career taking Amtrak not even in
Axela
nope in first class Amtrak using a bull
sandwich which I kind of loved and I
missed that sandwich get get into New
York not New York not even New York
which would be fun Woodbridge New Jersey
train station at like eight o'clock my
dad would pick me up we drive home and
then I would wake up at 6:30 in the
morning and work in the liquor store on
Sat
and then leave back to Boston on Sunday
and now I'm lucky it's hard to it's hard
to think you're lucky when you when
nobody else is needed rule number seven
keep things in perspective we put out a
shoe with k-swiss that was our third one
with them called clouds and dirt which
is basically my thesis in life which is
macro micro the have ambitions but you
have to you have to put in work to do
that right like you know everything
matters nothing matters just I'm a very
I'm a contradiction and within that
contradiction and a lot of people hit me
up they're like you're a stoic I'm like
what is that I googled I'm like oh maybe
maybe I am like I was like what what I
know I am is happy and I'm happy because
I keep things in perspective and keeping
things in perspective I just tweeted
something that said there's a very fine
line between perseverance and delusion
and it's this question of people always
ask me like when should I give up Gary
I've been doing this you know wrapping
thing I've been doing this vlog doing
this restaurant it's not going well two
and a half years in and I can never
answer it because you need to know the
nuances and the details sure but there
is an incredible inflection point in
everybody's life speaking about your
early childhood like acting the amount
of people that literally were like one
more audition this isn't working for me
one more audition and that's the one
right or one more song one more album
one more startup one more day at their
job there's a one more try to ask this
boy out there's all these things of like
when is it too much and you just waste
your life and you go into depression or
when was it perfect contradictions I'm
fascinated by them but I'm always on the
optimistic side of them mainly because
when it doesn't work out my big thing is
well you now know what doesn't work you
now know you aren't a rapper and good
news you're 31 you have your whole life
as a rule number eight be practical
do you understand how crazy it is that
if you went to the clearance aisles of
your five biggest retailers in Australia
bought things on clearance when home
relisted it and post it on eBay
that the far majority of this audience
could make between 50 to $100,000 a year
just on doing that for 9 to 10 hours a
day meanwhile everybody's sitting here
with the next big app that's gonna be
the next Bluebird for lawnmowers the
thing that has made me successful far
more than my passion or my energy is my
disproportionate practicality most
people want to look the part of an
entrepreneur that came up with the next
supreme or Adi dis brand or the next
uber or face book yet our $40,000 in
debt work in a job that they hate and
literally if they went to the 5 discount
stores that dominate this market buy
things on clearance go home take a
picture with their phone and upload to
eBay and then when people buy it go to
the post office and ship it they would
be able to get out of debt and get into
a financial place but people don't want
to do that because they don't want to be
judged for that being there hustle most
people in this room in this world would
rather lose looking like they're doing
something successful than win and be
judged for doing something that seems
Thor key rule number 9 love what you do
I think that there's a deep inherent
understanding in my in my mind that
there's only one at that and I don't
want to leave anything on the table most
people don't want to work most people
didn't find what they love
most people don't have enormous ambition
and most people prefer to you to stop
because it makes them insecure while you
keep winning Rick there's no greater
gift in life than to have the people you
love be happy and healthy the second
biggest gift in life is to love what you
do so much that you only want to work
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is be authentic
your question the life I like for me
yeah cuz it's my natural state cuz I'm
optimistic and positive I love to
compliment people if it's off that dick
like if I can you think you're purple
here is rad then I'll be like your
hair's amazing I would never do it if I
knew who you were and I wanted to get to
be your friend I wouldn't say it I
genuinely believe that intent rules the
world that if you're doing it for the
right reason you win I'd rather say
something about your jacket or your
sneakers or or just say hello but what
my favorite thing is is if there's
something that I want to complement
something on because it just starts to
Bob so nice
now I've got a really special bonus gift
from Gary and how to hold yourself
accountable that I think you're really
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to taking action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what's
the biggest mindset change that you need
to make number two how can you learn to
love the dark clouds and number three
what do you need to do a better job of
keeping in perspective
the reason I'm remarkably happy as a
human being is because my favorite word
and the framework of my life and how I
navigate it is accountability I am
stunned by the fact that most people
haven't wrapped their head around the
fact that accountability is what
actually leads to happiness
I'm also stunned that people still think
money is a parallel to happiness you
know if I could achieve anything tonight
it would be putting people in a place of
understanding the the far majority of
this room would be much happier making a
hundred thousand dollars a year than
making a million dollars a year
if you want more garyvee check at the
top 50 rules for success video I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there cuz
they're on the phone anymore and you
could talk about a day and age when it
was simpler and nicer and all this
nobody gives up